[Musik]
auftritt der
26-jährige ist ein star ingenia doch nur
mit harry security traut er sich in
seinem team fahren anzug auf die straße
sein leben spielt meist in den eigenen
vier wänden hier kann er sich verwandeln
die welt da draußen bedrohten denn
dennis ist schwul und dafür kann man in
kenia ins gefängnis kommen
um ehrlich zu sein und man muss eine
dicke haut entdeckte man muss sehr
widerstandsfähig werden sehr
konzentriert sein ja und man muss sich
einfach einen dreck scheren
es ist ein lachen aus bitterer erfahrung
schon immer wusste dennis ich bin anders
und das ist ein problem
der 26 jährige arbeitet als make up
artist seinen youtube videos folgen
zigtausende offen zugeben aber dass er
homosexuell ist niemals denn wer sich
dazu in china bekennt muss mit angriffen
rechnen und wird geächtet
an manchen orten nicht eingestellt
werden ich kann nicht frei arbeiten
nicht kann nicht frei nach draußen gehen
wir hängten einfach der entwicklung
hinterher ich denke dass wir alle
einbeziehen müssen dass ihr einfach alle
akzeptieren
auch für dennis familie war das am
anfang schwer inzwischen kauft seine
schwester schuld für sein studio ein für
ihn wäre es in kosmetik laden zu
gefährlich jeder zweite schule in kenia
hat schon offene gewalt erlebt auch
dennis wer beim sex erwischt wird wird
von der polizei verhaftet und landet
mehrere jahre im gefängnis jeden tag
fürchten um ihren bruder doch er ist
auch ihr vorbild
ich höre was seine fans über ihn sagen
dass er so vielen menschen mut gemacht
hat sie selbst zu sein und zu
akzeptieren wer sie sind und
sich zu outen und ihr leben so zu leben
in ihren familien gibt es dagegen kaum
verständnis
gottesdienst in einer gemeinde am
stadtrand von nairobi
die fahrerin der freikirche bekennt sich
offen zu ihrer homosexualität
wer zu ihr konto führt meist zu führen
community doch auch carolina motto hat
nie direkt mit ihren eltern darüber
gesprochen dass sie lesbisch ist
die leute reden die ganze zeit über dich
sogar in deiner familie deine mutter ist
nicht sicher weil die ganze
nachbarschaft über dich redet und das
betrifft auch deine eltern
sie wissen nicht wie sie mit ihr umgehen
sollen du trägst männerkleidung du
läufst wie ein mann und sie wissen nicht
was das ist
selbst meine mutter weiß bis heute nicht
was eine lesbe ist und was schwul ist
glaube und religion spielen im leben der
meisten kenianischen familien eine große
rolle sie bestimmen den alltag die
zukunft der kinder doch sie sind auch
gnadenlos wenn es um die geht die nicht
in die gemeindekassen ihr leben
selbstbestimmt leben wollen
bevor ich hierher komme will ich in eine
andere kirche gegangen
die meisten sehen uns als sonja
und weil sie uns als sünder sehen haben
wir nicht die zeit über uns selbst zu
reden
wir können nicht über unsere probleme
reden wenn wir welche haben
wir können nicht über unsere
unsicherheiten mit ihnen reden weil sie
uns eben als sünder sehen
weit außerhalb von kenias hauptstadt
leben menschen die wegen ihrer
homosexualität sogar um ihr leben
fürchten mussten wohin die fahrt gehen
dürfen wir nicht verraten denn hier
verstecken sich männer aus uganda in
ihrer heimat ist schon das schwulsein
selbst strikt verboten wer sich bekennt
wird sofort verhaftet sam nokia ist erst
vor einem tag angekommen geflogen über
einen fluss an der grenze immer lebte er
mit der angst für auto zu werden
ich habe versucht es zu verstecken aber
mein aussehen und mein gang mein
charakter haben einfach gezeigt was ich
bin als er 16 war wurde er von der
polizei verhaftet auf einem handy hatte
sie verdächtige fotos gefunden sam juli
im hochsicherheitsgefängnis lucia traute
sich monatelang nicht aus seiner zelle
ich wurde nach ihrer gebracht wo man mir
eine rote uniform mit der aufschrift gab
ich bin ein schwuler bleibt weg von mir
ich bin ein homosexueller bleibt weg von
mir das geben sie die
ihr leben teilen ähnliche erfahrungen
auch so
seit fünf jahren lebt er als flüchtlinge
in kenia in einem blog versuchte er
seine ängste sorgen erfahrungen mit der
community zu teilen und hat immer den
traum von einem anderen freieren lieben
die tatsache dass ich keine kinder haben
hat keine kinder von meinem partner
adoptieren dass ich nicht die hand
meines partners halten darf was
eigentlich eine grundlegende sache ist
jeder mensch haben sollte das tut mir
wirklich weh das spiel hat die suhler
hat lange sein körper verkauft um sich
über wasser zu halten jetzt hatte im
schutzhaus eine neue familie gefunden
und hofft auf asyl in den usa sowie auf
samuel solange aber ist er nur im haus
sicher
man kann nur in dieser kleinen box
glücklich sein in dieser eigenen welt
aber wenn man in diese andere welt geht
muss man sich auf eine bestimmte art und
weise verhalten damit man die
gesellschaftlichen normen und kulturen
erfüllen kann auch der discovery der
make up künstler denkt ab und zu darüber
nach seine heimat kenia zu verlassen
weil es hart ist für ihn und die anderen
der community ein selbstbestimmtes leben
zu führen und dafür zu kämpfen dass
jeder und jede sex mit wem auch immer
handelt denn es aber nicht aufgeben an
einen wandel zu glauben
ich habe erschlossen die leute zu
inspirieren sich zu outen denn ich will
veränderung
wenn ich also etwas ändern will muss
sich selbst die veränderung sein es muss
bei mir anfangen
es ist ein schwieriger weg für ihn und
die vielen anderen doch sie hoffen
darauf dass ihr entschlossener kampf am
ende über traditionen und konventionen